welcome to this video is this nice
Vallejo pons is this the real of a
little ponds probably not probably not
but it's actually forbidden to use real
people's names if you're not the guy so
but do we add can do we add him the long
thoughts and so this is a bit strange
but let's see what happens okay we
transpose to them to normal Quincy nian
let's let's go for the Petrosian system
should be six it's a bit unusual
just just play very norman developing
moves okay he has repaired to this
bishop this Bishop d6 move which really
didn't didn't belong into into the whole
position yeah
so how do we how are we going to play
that maybe this movie m-maybe d5 at some
moment if I go d5 now yes Knight takes
d5 but that's not such a problem right
no it isn't okay
so 55 I can see can take with the porn
actually which is not bad Reggie's gotta
be five as well okay work seemed
so before hmm okay I'm going to stop
that I'm still unsure about those tech
tech zeros 95 kind of tactics
this is a super fishy looking game the
whole account is fishy and the kind of
play is really fishy right okay let's
see very computer ish but if this is a
computer why is he not banned already
he's got 40 games in the in three minute
pool
hmm job right before it's coming I mean
I really don't have a great museum
I have many pieces in the vicinity of
the king but it is probably nothing
nothing really serious night to is six
or something I mean it's not going to
work probably but the only chance
getting as much near the King as
possible
notice how reliably is playing like
every is five or six seconds there's a
new move came so I can take here that he
will take him
okay white result yeah this is I mean
how clear do you want it to be yeah this
is just it's just computer abuse is
playing is playing in the Jataka opening
with Bishop d6 just whom you humiliate
the opponent yeah just like I can play
some crap moves you know but I'm still
going to win because I'm not making any
mistake now
no no it's no if you want that I can I
can I can show you well I give you I
give you I don't want to screw up the
whole thing
normally F with the computer email yeah
you see okay this is stockfish him I
don't know what he uses but he has an
engine so let's look at sd-6 play this
197 now I played rookie one okay c5 now
played did this he played takes I take
he plays b5 ROP 8 okay no rukia it
depends on the engine
but now b5 of course this is relatively
normal but you know where it starts this
kind of thing Queen b6 I take and now
Queen takes
yeah like after four seconds I mean I'm
not saying this is a totally unnatural
you know but you just go into the rock
here the very unhuman move as this this
is a normal-looking normal move that any
human would probably probably just play
it okay you played with the Queen here
and he just took it and look at this
look at the time span this is very
interesting
yeah five seconds five six seven seconds
four seconds three seconds is oh it's a
couple of seconds so yes'm it has the
Machine somewhere nearby and just just
repeated uses the moose and what I don't
understand is why is this guy not not
bandy idea because he already if you
know this is I mean just just is just a
total joke yeah he's got this is just
the same
35 wins two losses one draw yeah almost
perfect score in five minute and and he
is got this name I would smell smells of
cheating just look at this he lost one
game here which we can look at against
my away and let's see what he did how he
lost it I mean him just just go through
it just go through it quickly I mean
black is on the road to victory so
something something something went wrong
there IEP eight all the computer is
moves snatched all the material and
should win why isn't your winning
interesting an interesting question
probably not on time so here did he do
something like is winning we see that
are here here what is this he's giving
away this we see human after all
very very very weird but the whole thing
is some kind of strange well I will
report him and let's see let's see what
happens it looks very weird the whole
thing I mean the thing is if it is
really Francisco Vallejo ponds he needs
to have the GM near him and and the name
in there if you if you just call
yourself after a famous player you have
to be the player so this guy's I is via
hop-ons or cheetah now and the way it to
the whole games went here are pure
cheats this is really a bit weird maybe
you just wanted to to blunder sometimes
it's blundering everything yeah I don't
know what happened there okay well I
don't know if you've got anything out of
this game but the problem is if you if
you really think that the guy is
cheating you're not even able to play a
decent game I mean not I don't want to
excuse make excuses for my bed play in
this game I just kind of you yo you you
don't
you're not really playing because you
think where this guy is cheating anyway
okay anyway I will report him and let's
see what happens thanks for watching